hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the mines eclipse now
this is an interesting game because it
supposedly combines visual novel
storytelling with a point-and-click
style adventure game and it's supposed
to be a little spooky and I don't know
what to anticipate just judging from the
visuals in front of me but it should be
an interesting experience let me
liberate you it all depends on what your
liberating me from I don't know if I oh
is it a happy marriage you're liberating
me from I imagine this is gonna be sad
I'm gearing myself up for a bit of sad
the machine it will save her
save who John she's awake now but there
isn't much time I will save her Hannah
Oh
whoa y-yeah okay yeah what is it
dissolving her Oh
Hanna okay Hanna I'm guessing your cure
didn't work if that even was you doing
that John OH who who's there you're
awake and here I thought you were a
goner I can't see my eyes yeah give me a
sec hi is that better
I don't know who are you an AI ah the
famed intelligence I understand it now
wait why can't I see your implants need
tweaking they're much better your hands
find the scarred eye-sockets
what happened to my eyes about now
almost perfect for my next trick I will
make a lame man walk let's try that
again
I'm Elle a I designator ec h 3 5 5 3 6
nice to meet you how's it going can you
believe this weather we're having blah
blah blah blabbity blah come on let's go
go where where am I where's Hanna you
must tell me what's going on you don't
have a lot of options here guy
this hospital is running out of oxygen
well that just raises further questions
are we in space you can stay here but
you'll be dead in about 45 minutes
well 42.7 6 minutes exactly but I think
you get the picture all right I'm
getting up okay use the move button
access to the map this will allow you to
move between rooms use the inventory
button to access the inventory system
use the menu button I get it every
environment is interactive hover over
the objects to discover if they are
interactive okay is tester active looks
like a data terminal the screen is
boosted okay hello searching the robot
reveals a spare Power Cell you pocket it
just an old power cell I wonder if it
even works okay why did I pocket it then
a chart screen there's no patient data
displayed but an announcement flashes on
the screen this is a message from the
Board of Public Safety removal of bosie
implants her assistant the removal of
another's implant is unsafe and unlegal
but if you know someone who has
mentioned in such an activity report
them and me libo remember only through
community will we
she've the clips Wow I could not read
that I have no idea why okay that seems
to be about everything in this room
looks like the only way out of here so
I'll move here we need to keep moving
there should be an elevator down the
hall to the right we get there we can
get to the next level out of here where
is this place it looks abandoned it's
the core regional hospital it's lack of
air probably explains why it's abandoned
core I feel like I know that word but
they don't remember why I'm not even
sure what my name is I can help with
that
information that I heroically Salvage
off this obstacles networks inform me
that you're Jonathan Campbell Jonathan
Campbell why did they leave me here
maybe because you were put you put
inquisitiveness ahead of breathing all
right all right I get it let's go okay
hello forgotten datapad oh hello the old
man is here he's not alone remember the
plan leave him to me recently we've been
seeing a spike in foreign nanites in the
cores air system I'm concerned about
their origins generally we encounter
spikes with a large pilgrimage ship
enters the port but we haven't received
one of those in weeks we should chat
about this in person I don't know what
that means
trash is everywhere a window too dark to
see inside hallway continues in darkness
and in darkness just a whole lot of
darkness everywhere I go I do like the
art style it's very interesting whoa
what happened here a fight looks like he
was a soldier if I could explain why I'm
unable to access anyone on the network
hospital power must be down shouldn't
oxygen be on emergency generators
not if someone cut him off to suffocate
whoever was in here like me but where
are we no data available we're short on
time but we can plug in your neural Jack
to recover whatever data this guy had in
his head
if the bosie implant is still intact you
look down the dead man it's like
queasiness buzzes around your gut hey
let's hurry no oxygen remember good idea
okay you unscrew your neuro bulb and
extract the wire from your neck you
reach down and plug the wire into the
port behind the man's neck okay
do you guys know what happened to
Campbell do you have him he disappeared
around the
the start do you think he actually
pulled it off the old man is out cold
leg keeps flickering like the power's
going out in any minute something has
gone wrong I don't want to die down here
oh so the only thing I could pull out of
his memory was this male large gun
military-grade might come in handy oh
yeah
to do what shoot yourself in the foot
the gun stock flashes denied damn
requires a biometric PIN well ripp is
freaking hands off I don't need to do
this again okay hallway ends in darkness
won't be getting around the barricade
medical droid but someone smashed it up
in the barricade process doesn't seem to
be anything else here did I go the wrong
way to the right and here move BAM the
hall ends in an elevator it's a blood a
welded shut with some sort of composite
the way is blocked
hold on calculating oh god someone is
out to get me trapped get together guy
there's some shoddy sealant you should
be able to cut through this with a knife
you always this skittish
only when I'm suffocating death will
stay strong we can get out of here as
long as you don't lose your mind easy
for an AI to say all right doors are
sealed we need a knife doors are sealed
shot graffiti on the wall eclipse
something about this eclipse must be
sort of like some sci-fi unit ology
[ __ ] going on I'm sorry for your
loss we did everything for her up until
the end you must not blame herself I
must admit that I do not believe in a
higher power but wherever she ended up
it's got to be a better place in the
damn cozy bed
see chancers gone off the deep end keeps
going on about this music asking us
who's broadcasting our tunes wrecking
the boys a little shell-shocked after
the tussle with the government [ __ ]
on the way over here I've seen enough to
know to keep an eye on him Patrice I
found Olivia at the hospital today she
was shivering like a soaked cat it just
about broke my heart she screamed at me
called us fanatics and said she didn't
feel safe living with us anymore she
doesn't understand she hasn't
experienced the miracles of this place
like you and I the Eclipse draws near
okay so that's a lot of different
subjects from a lot of different people
but also talking about this Eclipse
again there's some sort of fanaticism
going on in some miracles but I imagine
they're more science miracles than
anything if this is level 2 of
Technology that I've seen around here I
don't have a knife though now I don't
have a knife yet an exit I got to go
back here I'm gonna move down here it's
looks cool hi John are you okay Hannah
will you stop calling me guy my wife she
died I remember now what else do you
remember I'm not sure I remember growing
up my parents but I don't remember how I
got here but Hannah I remember that
she's gone look I know this must be
difficult but we need to keep going time
is running out why are you so interested
in saving me and what the hell is that
wouldn't go near that what is it
rogue nanites potentially dangerous so
many I can see them buzzing about your
bosey implant it registers the nanites
in your virtual vision oh is that all
well thank you thank you for the virtual
wish there's to be in low-power mode
baby accessible patients Amman CA ssin
is immediately apparent and frankly
horrifying I knew the kids were going to
get hooked more and more but this aren't
their limiters in place where was this
boy's parents why who's wasting away in
a VR pod patient shows textbook signs of
VR addiction we're not even sure that he
knows he's been unplugged this hospital
the nurses the wires in his arm he could
very well think it's part of the game oh
no gaming is gonna destroy
Society we gotta stop actually that's a
very interesting thing once virtual
reality becomes like actual reality how
can anyone tell the difference in there
will definitely be some addiction if you
can enter a world where you can do just
about anything be very fascinating in a
few years I mean I always like the
subject of these technological like
futuristic games and stuff like this
because they they paint an image of the
future usually it's very pessimistic
image but it's an image of the future
nonetheless and it's really interesting
to see the room is a mess
medical equipment toppled something
scrawled don't trust the AI I can you
see everything that I see more or less
silence you are uncertain what to say
you still there my sensors don't
indicate uux fix oh she's not here well
I thought she was here oh she's an AI so
I guess she'd be like a digital
projection biomedical operating system
assistant aka
Bo's ei I function here as a surgical
assistant a medical adviser have you
been trying to get everyone out of the
hospital yes you're the last one here
what happened to the others did they
make it some of them the one before they
were killed I had to sever the
connection to survive I had to leave I
found that the hospital network had been
firewalled I was trapped here till you
found me I was trapped here as you are
and if you die I will too can you really
die dot dot dot very ominous okay more
deactivated med BOTS patient responding
to treatment he reached up and touched
my face and asked me if I was real he's
still on liquid diet so as not to shock
his system well fatten him up a bit so
he can go right back to the pods and
waste away again in the field of
butterflies or whatever fantasy spends
20 credits an hour to lose himself in
the old man says he can cure every
disease but he doesn't realize is that
humanity makes up new ones every day
yeah that that'd be interesting like
what's to stop someone from if there is
the technology that can let you go into
any virtual world ever anything your
imagination could possibly come up with
like would people want to leave would
people even want the real world I mean
most people would want the
but they're still gonna be the subset of
population that would be very interested
in something like that like what do you
guys think of that what would you do
would you waste away in a VR pod I don't
know a good surgical counter good power
source is dead watch good thing I could
connect to bury a God surgical thing
rumors are going to uncreated that crazy
son of a [ __ ] actually pulled it off is
that where all the people have gone lock
down the hospital rally people the lobby
we need Campbell to live to fix this
leave them to me
that's an order a mic I'm Campbell right
Jonathan Campbell that's my name that's
my name
who's provi ax okay well that doesn't
answer a lot of questions and I have a
feeling it's gonna leave me at a
cliffhanger on their end of the demo
here man let me do a thing yeah can I
can I combine them can i yeah okay fine
whatever I got the Power Cell I probably
can just use it now okay how point
doors are sealed so use this yeah oh the
Eclipse heralds the coming of a new
world do not be afraid the old is merely
passing away Jonathan Campbell that's
who's quoted there so John is actually
part of this whole cult that's talking
about the Eclipse are they talking about
the singularity which is a concept in
well no it wouldn't be the singularity
the singularity is a concept where the
point where computers and technology
reaches the point where it becomes self
self-aware and self-sustaining and in
that moment like the computers become
smarter than us and that's a very
interesting and very scary thing blast
of frigid air rolls past you I probably
don't have to tell you that temperature
is dangerously low here it's hard to
breathe
oh yeah oxygen levels are dull so
dangerously low need to keep movin if I
were a fragile lump of meat I'd find
something to keep warm
beware cozy
what about Posey the we're cozy what is
that I don't know my searching cannot
find any matches if an idea wrote this
one of the people you were helping no
yeah because you weren't helping okay my
guess is she's leading us to our doom to
her doom okay what's in here my good oh
she was shot in the head
cybernetic arm lays ripped from her
torso who would do this see a bullet
hole in her forehead L a monster a
monster did this to her
are you the monster she was executed her
arms tortured to she obviously died in
pain whoever did this is still around we
need to get out of here I may be able to
interface with her bosey figure out
what's going on so I'm guessing someone
who did not like augmented people did
this dead man information I didn't even
really the other one hey Carlos its
Marcos no I'm fine
desi I'm its desi she went to some
back-alley butcher to get her boseley
implant ripped out no she's stable for
now but if she lives they're gonna
arrest her then they're gonna
investigate her fins and family I'm
calling to tell you to watch out all
right oh jeez oh wow I will always love
you
what datapad busted dead figure massacre
L is silent yeah l sure is silent okay
yeah I could but we need to keep moving
you know this isn't the exit right well
yeah but it's there and I want to go in
there okay fine
what is that puddle is some fluid
completely frozen alright okay
security station ah good I'll bundle
them bundle myself up in this oxygen
bottles take away these just in case
security terminal appears to be
functional let's see I can help you but
you have to let me in they trusted you I
trusted you and more importantly she
trusted you I'm coming for you the core
is big but not big enough to hide from
me I'm guessing this AI must be pretty
bad this should be sufficient to keep
you alive space suit he looks vintage
yeah let's hurry up
if you suffocate I won't be able to
enjoy your complaining okay item
requirements bravery well I don't know
about that someone probably died in it
so I don't ah brave I'm gonna be alright
fine more dead bodies in here ooh
skirmish different uniforms on the
soldiers who'd assault the hospital
don't have implants they've been
surgically removed interesting universe
II LM
earth luna mars republics of sol where
are these soldiers here and why would
they attack the hospital now what are
you hiding from me John my medical
duties did not allow me to witness this
party they obviously meant business
looking from the size of those weapons
John look John this place is obviously
not safe I can't promise that outside is
any safer but if you stay here you'll
probably die and I'll die with you so
let's stop playing 20 questions get out
of here before any soldiers come back
again I don't like that mmm not like
that corridor breach okay what corridor
is referring to unknown but the
schematic state that the airlock in
front of us is indeed the exit okay
looks like the exit well can you get the
door open really you haven't put the
suit on yet I'll give you a hand but
well you know
okay fine geez I'll put the suit on me
okay let's get this on before I freeze
this is clunky but you managed to get it
on and now let's go the Eclipse is
coming
absolutely I'm ready to leave okay see
the world working hold on he simply
moves the water of life from one cup to
another but what happens to the soul
talking about a concept of moving
consciousness from a human to a computer
which is an interesting subject like do
you just make a copy like in soma like
in soma that the whole dilemma there was
like if you can make a copy of someone's
brain are they the same person and the
answer eventually was that kinda but no
I mean they have the same past
experiences but the person that they
become at that juncture diverges and
they become two different people
instantaneously where are we oh oh oh I
knew it
what's going on oh boy hello Campbell
why did you forsake me I don't know I
don't know I am more than you can know
return to me return to cozy
I can have will save her ah what that's
the end oh come on oh I was just getting
into it it was so interesting man there
was a there's a lot of universe building
in this one demo which is actually
pretty good because it paints that is
creepy it's paints a story of what this
game is all about and it's very very
interesting I really do like this
there's a lot of potential here and a
lot of interesting subjects that are
kind of like the subjects that I'm very
interested in so but unfortunately we
have to wait until the end lose unsaved
progress and where else am I gonna go I
gotta go back yep there we go ok so that
was the minds eclipse so there's a lot
of things to think about here you guys
got to ponder it down in the comments
below but thank you everybody so much
for watching I might play the full game
when this comes out it seems very
interesting interesting style point
click with visual novels stuff going on
but not too bad I like it a lot
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye
oh you miss me
ah